the heart of London at the height of
rush hour a different looking city a
different looking country an
unprecedented level of executive power
now required to cope with coronavirus
emergency Clause 321 pages of them
published today from helping the public
by widening access to sick pay and
changing rules for hospitals and schools
to help in the government keep a handle
on the crisis new powers to detain
infectious people ban gatherings even
suspend ports the pace and scale of
change extraordinary and bewildering the
Prime Minister today trying to give an
anxious nation some hope with a hint of
an exit date I do think looking at it
all that we can turn the tide within the
next 12 weeks and I'm absolutely
confident that we can send a coronavirus
and hopes of a vaccine today we've put
the first British corona patient into a
randomized trial for drugs that may
treat the disease UK experts scientists
expect to start trials for the first
vaccine within a month a bit of hope
there you're suggesting to the public
that if they follow the rules that you
can turn the tide on this disease are
you telling people that by the summer
they might they just might be able to go
back to normal life be able to go on
their summer holidays I'm very confident
that we'll get this thing done I'm very
confident that we'll beat coronavirus I
think we can turn the tide within the
next 12 weeks but it depends on
collective resolute action but a rare
admission from the Prime Minister not
everyone is doing their bit as he keeps
in reserve stricter measures to force
them some evidence that in some parts of
the of the capital it's it's very patchy
and some some air
where people aren't perhaps following it
in quite the way that we need them to do
the queen leading by example leave in
London with Prince Phillip tonight to
begin their home isolation at Windsor
Castle promising that she and her family
stand ready to play their part in this
national effort as she asked her people
to play there's Beth Rigby Sky News
Westminster